[Applause]
[Music]
what if i told you that there is a group
of people out there who have been
accused of everything from human rights
violations to dealing drugs to enabling
murder the good news is those people are
currently in prison the bad news is they
aren't the inmates let me explain in a
segment called how did we get here
tonight we're going to talk about prison
conditions and that can be tough because
a lot of people assume that prisons are
filled with bad people so we don't need
to worry about them so let me get this
out of the way up top yes prisons may be
filled with people who have made at
least one bad decision but so are
nickelback concerts and divorce court
and yet we still treat those people like
human beings so we need to do the same
for prisoners now
a few months ago the u.s department of
justice filed a civil rights lawsuit
against the state of alabama now this is
interesting for two reasons first
because i didn't know you could sue a
whole state freaking watch your back
florida and
second because the lawsuit says
alabama's poor management is leading to
homicides rapes and serious injuries in
its prisons alabama has the most violent
prison system in america and having the
most violent anything in america is a
very big deal it's like having the
flakiest croissant in france or being
the most unhinged person in a facebook
thread
now i know i said that i'd explain all
this to you but honestly i am not sure
that i can now the good news is i don't
have to instead we have quotes from
inmates inside the alabama department of
corrections you'll hear some tonight and
they are 100 real so let's start with
the living conditions saying that
alabama prisons are overcrowded is like
saying that shonda rhimes shows are
slightly horny sure it's true but it's
also a huge understatement
the bibb county correctional facility in
brent alabama was built to hold 918
inmates it currently houses over 1700
the elmore correctional facility was
built for 600 people and now has 960
inmates they there are clowns in tiny
cars who hear those numbers and say
that's too crowded
now with the overcrowding and unsanitary
conditions in those prisons it is not
surprising that covid is raging elmore
the facility with 960 inmates had 191
people test positive in one day which is
horrifying usually the only time you see
that much alarming positivity is when
you're watching the sound of music
really maria brown paper packages that's
your favorite raise your standards girl
maria i need you to listen to me if you
marry him you are going to be doing the
same job you're doing right now but for
free don't fall for it
and even worse once the prisoners get
sick they are often ignored across the
u.s prisons haven't done enough to
quarantine sick inmates putting everyone
around them in grave danger of getting
sick or even dying according to the
bureau of justice statistics
being incarcerated in alabama is three
times deadlier than cancer and deadlier
than cancer is one of those phrases you
should never have to hear like bloodier
than squid game or dumber than a kushner
unfortunately it gets worse because one
of the deadliest hazards in the alabama
prison system is the guards themselves
an inmate named james said i've been
stabbed four times i've been beaten so
many times i can't even count none of
those stabbings came from an inmate not
one of those beatings came from an
inmate
now if you're thinking maybe that
prisoner is lying that's fair let's hear
from another one larry said the guards
are handcuffing these inmates and
beating them and killing them and bj who
was incarcerated said said of his
experience the physical abuse is rampant
rape is everywhere it is like living in
a zoo but hey maybe you don't believe
any prisoners then listen to the doj
report that talks about an officer who
took a handcuffed and compliant inmate
out of an observation room threw him
onto the ground and then punched kicked
and beat him with a baton and when he
was finished his supervisor who had
watched the whole thing said that's fair
i want to look at you right now and say
this isn't who we are america but until
we learn to treat human beings with
dignity and stop letting this happen in
our names it's exactly who we are
remember when bj said living in prison
was like living in a zoo well here's the
difference if this had happened in a zoo
people would be rioting in the streets
to make sure it never happens again
don't let a white person hear about a
sad giraffe they will lose their minds
now i know some of you might be saying
this sounds terrible but what does it
have to do with me well first of all the
alabama prison system is the worst
example but prisons all over the country
have similar issues but also
now that they're using federal money to
build those prisons you are an investor
and that means you get a say so how can
you make a difference well the good news
is there are already people working on
these issues you can donate your time or
money to places like the equal justice
initiative and if you specifically want
to help alabama inmates donate to the
alabama appleseed center for law and
justice but most importantly we can't
just look away because these are our
cousins and our uncles and our fathers
and our sons they are us
hell it could be me i have a
best-selling book two tv jobs and my own
show but every day i leave the house
knowing that if i cross paths with the
wrong police officer when they're having
a bad day and looking for someone to
take it out on i could be in jail
tomorrow y'all i'll be talking about she
shouldn't have been talking to the
officer like that please
america's prison problem is not some
distant problem it's our problem and i
know i said i'd explain all this but in
this one case i do not know exactly how
we got here i just know that it's time
to get out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you